Transcriber: Metin Akın
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Bana bakınca ne düşünüyorsunuz?
Aslında biliyorum.
''Bir ön yargıyı kırmak, atomu
parçalamaktan daha zordur.''
Albert Einstein.
Bugün buraya bu zorlu görev için geldim.
Ben Melis.
Ben Esma.
Ben Rana
Ben Jacquelin.
Ben Berfin.
Evet bugün burada belki Melis
olarak duruyorum ama
beni şu anda tamamen
kimliksiz ve ön yargısız
sadece kadın olarak
dinlemenizi istiyorum.
Zor olduğunu biliyorum.
Benim yaşadığım ülkede şöyle bir laf var:
''Bir ortamda sessizlik olduğu zaman,
bir yerlerde kız çocuğu doğdu'' deniyor.
Henüz kız çocuğunun doğduğu yeri
çiçek tarlasına çevirdiğinden
kimsenin haberi yok.
İşte ben buraya bugün bu yüzden geldim.
Daha doğduğumuz an itibariyle
bizim üzerimize yüklenen o kasveti
şu balonun içine koyup
elimdeki bu iğneyle
patlatmak için geldim.
Zor görünüyor biliyorum
ama biz beraber bunu yapabiliriz.
Bunun için iki şeye ihtiyacımız var.
Bir ön yargıları kırmak,
iki cesaret etmek.
Bir kadın olarak ön yargıları
ikiye ayıracağım.
Kadınlara karşı ön yargılar
ve bizim, kendi ön yargılarımız.
Zira bugün kadınlar olarak
en büyük problemimiz
birbirimize olan ön yargılarımız.
Biz kadınlar olarak birbirimize
yaşam hakkı tanımamaya başladık
farkında mısınız?
Biz birbirimizin özgürlüğüne engel olarak
kendi özgürlüğümüzün önüne
engel koymaya başladık.
Yapılan bir araştırmaya göre Twitter’da
İngiltere merkezli bir araştırma kuruluşu
Demos yapıyor bu araştırmayı,
Twitter'da kadın düşmanı içerikli
yaklaşık 300 bin tweet'in,
yüzde 98 gibi bir oranı
gene kadınlar tarafından yazılıyor.
Ben, kendi Instagram'ıma baktığım zaman
bana gelen bütün kötü yorumlar
bütün kötü mesajlar
hepsi hemcinslerim tarafından geliyor.
Öyle kötü deyince lütfen aklınıza
hakaret ya da kötü söz gelmesin.
Direk olarak kendimi kötü
hissetmem için yazılan şeyler.
Peki bana şunun cevabını verin.
Hiç tanımadığı bir kadına,
neden başka bir kadın kendini
kötü hissettirmek ister?
Ön yargı.
Şöyle düşünün.
Bir kadınsınız ve sokakta yürüyorsunuz.
Karşı taraftan size doğru
başka bir kadın geliyor.
Bu kadının sizden tamamen
farklı olduğunu düşünün.
Tamamen farklı bir görüntüsü var.
Farklı din, farklı dil, farklı kültür.
Aslında ben Melis olarak
o kadar eminim ki.
Sizi birbirinden ayıran
tek şey doğduğunuz yer
ama siz o an için farklı olduğunuzu
düşünüyorsunuz.
Sizce ilk hamleniz ne oluyor?
Ben söyleyeyim.
Süzmek.
Şöyle bi' tepeden tırnağa bakmak
ya da ani göz hareketiyle bakmaya
dahi tenezzül etmemek.
''Sen benden farklısın, o yüzden
hemen koşarak benden uzaklaş''
diye bağırıyorsunuz.
İyi de sen kimsin?
Ben kimim?
Siz kimsiniz?
Biz kadınız.
Biz insanız.
Bizim hayattaki mücadelemiz bir.
Bizim kendimizi kanıtlamakla
ilgili savaşımız bir.
Bizim gözyaşlarımız bir.
Bizim kahkahalarımız ortak.
Bizim kalbimiz aynı sizinle.
Bunu nasıl görmeyebiliyorsunuz?
Karşınızdakini bir bez parçasıyla
ya da kaşıyla gözüyle
ona böyle bir şiddet uygulamaya
nasıl cesaret edebiliyorsunuz?
O zaman sokakta bas bas
bağırdığımız ''kadına şiddete hayır''
cümlesinin eylem ayağı direk
kendimiz olmuyor muyuz?
Bu yaptığımızın karşımızdaki kadında
tokattan başka bir etkisi yok. İnanın.
Hanımlar, beyler!
Bir şey kabul etmekten başlayalım.
Hepimiz önyargılarla
donatılmış durumdayız
ve vücudumuzdaki önyargılar
aslında terbiye edilebilir özelliklerdir.
O yüzden biz bugün bunu
burada değiştireceğiz.
Şimdi şu bilinçsiz ön yargıya dair
ufak bir hikâye hatırlatmak istiyorum.
Bir gün bir adam oğlu ile beraber arabada
giderken bi' trafik kazası geçirirler.
Çok şiddetli bir kazadır.
Adam hemen oğlunu kucağına alır,
hastaneye götürür.
Hastanenin acilinden içeri girerler.
Çocuk kan revan içinde,
ameliyata alınması gerekir,
hemen ameliyathaneye getirilir.
Cerrah içeri girer, kıyafetlarini giyer.
Eldivenlerini takar.
Cerrah tam ameliyata başlayacakken,
ellerini kaldırır.
“Ben ameliyat edemem” der.
''Bu benim oğlum''
Yani aslında çok şaşırtıcı bir şey yok.
Cerrah çocuğun annesidir.
Ama neden bu kadar sessizlik oluyor?
Çünkü hikayenin sonuna gelene kadar
hepimiz cerrahın erkek
olduğuna o kadar emindik ki.
İşte bilinçsiz ön yargı.
Şimdi bilinçli ya da bilinçsiz ön yargılar
bu kadar açık olarak önümüzde duruyorken
biz neden bunu değiştirmeyelim?
Kadınlar, siz, kadınlarım!
Biz bu değişimin öncüsü olabiliriz.
'Melis, sen şimdi neden kadınlara
bir yük daha yüklüyorsun?'
diye iç geçirenler oluyor biliyorum.
Şöyle açıklayayım:
Dünya üzerindeki
her suçlu bireyi düşünelim.
İyi suçlar, kötü suçlar,
suç işlemiş kadın ya da erkekleri
gözünüzün önüne getirin
ve kendinize şu soruyu sorun:
Bu kişi dünyaya suçlu olarak mı gelmiştir?
Hayır.
Peki bu kişiyi hayata kim getirmiştir?
Ya da hayata bu kişiyi kim hazırlamıştır?
Anne.
Lütfen arada 'baba' diyenlere
müsade etmeyin.
Zira o babayı da dünyaya
bir anne getirmiştir.
Peki, her anne nedir?
Bir kadındır.
Hemen ekleyeyim anne olmak için
doğurmanın şart olmadığı gibi
her kadının da dünyaya bir çocuk getirmek
gibi bir zorunluluğu da asla yoktur.
Ama anne olmayan kadınların da
dünyanın bir yerinde belli bir zamanda
hayata birilerini hazırladığına
emin olabilirsiniz.
O yüzden döngünün başı döndü
yine biz kadınlara geldi?
Şimdi biz bunu üzerimize
yüklenen bir ağırlıkmış gibi alıp
bunun altında ezilip, şikayet edeceğimize
bunun bir güç olduğunu düşünsek.
Hep beraber hareket etsek,
bunu bir avantaja çevirsek.
Bakın, bir kadın değişirse
devirler değişir.
Bir kadın gülümsemeye başlarsa,
o bütün mahalle kahkaha atar.
Bir ailede bir kadın bilinçlenirse
o evden sağlıklı bireyler çıkar.
Aslında bunun için dünyayı
baştan yaratmamıza gerek yok.
Yani bizim kadınlık
kodlarımızda aslında bu var.
Hiçbir sosyal faktör olmadan,
hiçbir çevresel etkin olmadan
biz aslında kadınlar olarak
yaratılıştan birbirimizi seviyoruz.
Bizim korkacak bir şeyimiz yok.
Kadınlar korkutucu değil inanın bana.
Bunu da örneklendireceğim.
Bir kadınsınız gece yarısı
sokakta yürüyorsunuz.
Kaldırımınızda giderken aynı kaldırımdan
size doğru başka bir kadın gelse
kaldırım değiştirir misiniz?
Hayır.
Ya da asansörde yukarı çıkarken,
hemcinsleriniz asansöre girse
çantanızı önünüze kıstırıp, şöyle bir adım
karşı tarafa döner misiniz?
Hayır.
Ya da bir bankta oturuyorsunuz
ve yanınıza başka bir kadın geliyor.
Soluklanmak için oturuyor
ve size birazcık yanaşıyor.
Hemen kendinizi geri çeker misiniz?
Hayır.
Çocuğunuzla sokakta yürüyorsunuz
ve karşı taraftan hemcinsiniz bir kadın
çocuğunuzu sevmek için geliyor.
Hemen müsade etmez misiniz?
Tamam işte.
Biz buna dönmek zorundayız.
Zaten bizim yaratılışımız bu.
Bakın kadınlar, hayatta her ne ile
suçlanıyorsak suçlanalım.
Ki biliyorum evet bir sürü
şeyle suçlanıyoruz.
Mesela yaşlanmakla suçlanıyoruz.
Bu çok bizim elimizde çünkü.
Ya da mesela hamilelikte şişen
ayaklarımızla suçlanıyoruz.
Hemen bir bilgi vereyim:
Dünya üzerinde her 90 saniyede 1 kadın
hamileliğinde ya da doğumunda ölüyor.
Dolayısıyla biz, evet hamileliğimizde
ayağımız şişiyor diye çok suçluyuz.
Ya da çok konuşmak ile
suçlanıyoruz mesela
çünkü erkekler günde
4 bin kelime kullanırken
biz kadınlar günde
7 bin kelime kullanıyoruz.
Evet, tamam kabul ediyorum.
Bu büyük bir suç.
Tamam, her neyse o.
Biz ne kadar çok şeyle
suçlanırsak suçlanalım.
İster dik başlı olalım.
İster sessiz olalım.
İster içimize kapanık olalım.
İster bağıra çağıra yaşayalım.
Her ne olursak olalım, birbirimizi sevmek
öyle kabul etmek zorundayız.
Sevgi bulaşıcıdır.
Sevgi iyileştiricidir.
Biz neden bunun öncüsü olmayalım?
Biz neden bu işin bayrağını taşımayalım?
Şu bize yüklenen o kusursuzluk denen şey
başımızın en büyük belası.
Bize daha doğduğumuz an itibariyle kadın
olarak ailemizde, çevremizde,
sosyal çevremizde, okul yaşantımızda,
iş yaşantımızda
hatta bugün günümüzde sosyal medyada bile
kusursuz olmamız bekleniyor.
Biz bu kadar kusursuz olma
beklentisiyle büyütülürken bir o kadar da
korkak olmamız bekleniyor.
Şimdi biz hem korkak hem kusursuz
olmayı nasıl becereceğiz?
Kız çocukları büyürken düştüklerinde
''ay, dur öpeyim geçsin'' yapıp.
Erkek çocukları düştüğünde
''erkek adam ağlamaz'' diyerek
nasıl biz bu çocukların
kusursuz olmamalarını
ya da korkmamalarını sağlayabiliriz?
Mümkün değil.
Zaten bu söylediğim şey,
en büyük evrensel problemlerimizden biri.
Bir toplumda erkeklerin duygularını
yaşamasına ne kadar müsaade edilirse
o toplumda kadınlar o kadar özgürleşir.
Nasıl ki erkeklerin hassas olmak,
kırılgan olmak gibi hakları var.
Biz kadınların da güçlü olmak
gibi bir hakkımız var.
Yine bir istatistik vermek isterim.
Yapılan araştırmalara göre
iş başvurularına yollanan CV'lerde
başarı kriterleri özdeş olmasına rağmen
yönetici pozisyonlarına başvuru yapan
erkek adaylarının isimleri sadece
Ayşe yerine Ali olduğu için
çok daha fazla işe kabul edilip
çok daha fazla maaşla
çalışmaya başlıyorlar.
Tamam.
Bu bilinen bir şey.
Burada beni ilgilendiren nokta şu:
bu işe kabul edilmeyen Ayşe'lerin
yüzde 96’sı gibi bir oranı:
anne.
Bu bize diyor ki kadınlar
anne olduktan sonra
zaten kariyer olarak
o noktada görülmüyorlar.
Ama baba olan Ali’ler için
asla aynı şey geçerli değil.
Yani buradan şunu söylemek istiyorum.
Biz kadın olarak herhangi bir iş, hangi iş
olursa başta ev kadınlığı da olmak üzere
ne işi yapmak istersek yapalım.
Ne kadar başarılı notlar alırsak alalım.
Ne kadar iyi okullara gidersek, gidelim.
Boğazımıza kadar hırsa
boğulmuş olursak, olalım.
Hatta ne kadar başarılı evlilikler
yaparsak yapalım.
Başarılı evlilik ne?
Kimse bilinmiyor.
Her ne olursa olsun bizim üzerimize
yüklenen o kusursuzluk durumu
bizim her zaman risk almaktan
korkmamıza sebep oluyor.
Adım atmaktan çekinmemize sebep oluyor.
Ya bırakın, bırakın kusurlu olalım.
Varsın bağırış çağırış hep beraber
kusurlarımızı haykıralım.
Diğer kadınların
kusurlarını kabul edelim.
Ancak o zaman cesur olmaya
bir adım daha yaklaşabiliriz.
Biz çocuklarımıza cesur olmayı
öğretmek zorundayız.
Biz çocuklarımıza kabul görmek için
sevgi kazanmak için
mükemmel olmak gerekmediğini söylemeliyiz.
Biz hep beraber çocuklarımızın kulağına
aynı şeyi fısıldamalıyız.
Susma.
Susmasın bizim çocuklarımız.
Özellikle kız çocukları daha doğduğu
andan itibaren cefakâr olmak,
kendini evine adamak,
kafasını önüne eğip
başına her ne geliyorsa gelsin,
susmak öğretiliyor.
Şimdi bu çocuk büyüdüğü zaman
tek doğrusu bu olduğu için
o da kendi çocuklarına
aynı şeyi öğretiyor.
Hayır, sen buraya gidemezsin.
Hayır, sen bunu giyemezsin.
Hayır, bu iş sana göre değil.
Sen bunu beceremezsin.
Sen bunun altından kalkamazsın.
Hiç sen o işe bulaşma.
Sen bu saatte ekmek almaya gidemezsin.
Zira yaşı senden küçük bile olsa
o evde bir erkek kardeşin var.
Bu çocuklar büyüyüp anne olduğunda
kendi çocuklarına susmayı öğretiyorlar.
O zaman bir yardım edin.
Bi' kerecik olsun hep beraber
cesaretlendirebilir miyiz kadınlarımızı?
Öne çıkmaya, konuşmaya, eyleme geçmeye,
birbirini sevmeye
ve cesur olmaya cesaretlendirebilir miyiz?
Bakın, kadın hakları üzerine konuşmak
asla bir erkek düşmanlığı değildir.
Zira bugün zaten ülkenin hiçbir yerinde
ya da Dünya'da hiçbir ülkede
cinsiyetçi eşitlik gibi bir şey
söz konusu değil.
O yüzden bu konu üzerine gitmek
bizi hiç bir adım öteye götürmez.
Biz kadınlar olarak önce
bi' kendimize döneceğiz.
Önce bi' dönüp bakacağız.
Biz değişimi kendimizden başlatacağız.
Kendimizden. Yanımızdakinden. Ailemizden.
Mahallemizden başlatacağız değişimi.
Önce biz bir kadın kadına
barış sağlayacağız.
Çünkü senin de,
senin de,
evet senin de.
Hepinizin içinde biryerde bir ben var.
Biliyorum.
Evet, belki anne olan Melis yok.
Evet, belki evlat Melis yok ya da
oyuncu Melis yok, fark etmez.
Ama bir yerde öyle bir hissin var ki,
ben ona düştüm ya da düşeceğim.
Biz bunu hep beraber yapmak zorundayız.
Sevgili kızım Ada
Hayır, sen doğduğunda bir sessizlik
olmadı bizim evimizde
aksine, sevindik biz.
Sen, şanslı dünyaya gelenlerdensin.
Hatta günümüze bakıldığında
sen belki ayrıcalıklısın da
çünkü biz, kız çocuğusun diye
daha az sevmiyoruz seni
ya da kız çocuğusun diye
daha az güvenmiyoruz sana
ama sakın Ada.
Sakın bize güvenme.
Kendine güven.
Kadınlığına güven.
Kimseyi sakın görünüşüyle filtreleme.
Eğer illa ki bir filtreleme yapacaksan,
kalbiyle filtrele insanları.
Sen dünyayı değiştirebilirsin.
Seni seviyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Teşekkür ederim.
Hanımlar, beyler!
Kadınlar, adamlar!
Bugün burada değişimi
beraber başlatabiliriz.
Lütfen ön yargılarımızı kıralım.
Herkesi olduğu gibi kabullenmeye
şimdi burada başlayalım
ve erkekler lütfen kadınlardan korkmayın.
Yok ya da vazgeçtim,
siz korkun
çünkü biz dünyayı değiştirebiliriz.
Evet, tamam.
Son olarak, beni bugün bu salonda dinleyen
ve sonradan dinleyecek olan tüm kadınlar.
Sizi bir adım öne çıkmaya davet ediyorum.
Görünür olmaya,
ön yargılarımızı kırarak,
birbirimizi severek
fark yaratmaya davet ediyorum.
Şimdi değilse ne zaman?
(Alkışlar)
Teşekkür ederim.